the speaker of the Arkansas House of
Representatives stabbed a man to death
on the floor of the chamber in 1837
Speaker of the House John Wilson was
presiding over a debate on Wolf bounties
when representative Joseph Anthony
suggested an amendment to the
legislation Wilson found the suggestion
offensive and responded by stabbing
Anthony in the heart with a Bowie knife
although Wilson was expelled from his
office it took 3 days for him to finally
be arrested the trial was moved to a
different County where Wilson stayed
with the judge in the trial and even
paid for his meals the jury returned a
verdict of excusable homicide and set
Wilson free Wilson returned the gesture
by taking the jury out for drinks
immediately after the trial 2 years
later Wilson was voted back into office
yes this really happened